good morning believe nation today's
message is express yourself over to you
Bruce Lee you see actually I do not
teach you no karate because I do not
believe in styles anymore I mean I do
not believe that there is such thing as
like Chinese way of fighting or the
Japanese way of fighting or whatever way
of fighting because unless human being
have three arms and four legs we will
have a different form of fighting but
basically we have only two hands and two
feet so Styles tends to a not only
separate man you know because they have
their own doctrines and then the
doctrine became the gospel truth you
know that you cannot change you know and
but if you do not have styles if you
just say well here here I am you know as
as a human being how can i express
myself totally and completely now that
way you won't create a style because
style is a crystallization you know I
mean that way it's a process of
continuing growth this is a really
important message and for me what I take
from it is don't follow the rules don't
follow the rules that your parents set
up for you don't follow the rules that
your culture Society tells you to do
don't feel like you have to be boxed in
like you are put into this little box
and you have to follow these set of
rules and you can't break free where
when you realize that you can break free
and you can do whatever you want and you
can challenge those rules that's where
your true expression is gonna come and
that's where you're gonna be happy
because as entrepreneurs we hate rules
right we like changing things up we like
being creative we hate being boxed in we
hate being told what to do and as long
as you have those pressures on you then
you're never going to be able to be your
true self and really express yourself
you have to really figure out if you're
living your life or someone else's
version of your life right are you doing
this because your parents or your
friends or your culture is telling you
to do it or are you doing it because you
really want
do it and the more you can express
yourself the more you can be true to
yourself more you can put that out in
the product or service you're creating
the more success you're going to have
the more happiness you're gonna have the
more money you're going to make and the
greater impact you're gonna have so my
question today for you today is what
holds you back from really expressing
yourself leave it in the comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso